but if it makes the car
[Music]
hey guys it's me Debbie
so Abbi I saw your pregnancy
announcement on your feet so first of
all big congratulations for me but more
importantly I want to let you know that
I'm also expecting yeah
hashtag pregnancy twins well I'm a bunch
of besties who had terrible morning
sickness and they told me all the best
ways to beat those tummy troubles so
today I'm gonna be educating you yeah
the tables have turned
oh thank you so much for the sincere
congratulations Debbie and a big
congratulations to you too that's
amazing we are super excited I'm not
gonna lie but I am not excited about the
morning sickness you know I thought I
was gonna be let off easy but then it
hit me and then it hit me really hard
but please enlighten me Deb let's
compare notes that hopefully we can come
to the bottom of this and I won't yak
all over your onesie oh God okay I'm on
it
first of all ginger it's all about the
ginger my bestie Tiffany it swears by it
she either drinks ginger tea sniffs
ginger or Tucson ginger candies
oh I hear you Deb I honestly lived off
these ginger candies for the first 14
weeks so interesting note ginger is the
only nonfarm illogical intervention
recommended by the American College of
obstetrics and gynecology
so ginger works by stimulating our GI
tract and our saliva and in a few
randomized controlled trials women who
are treated with ginger powder
experienced fewer Nadja symptoms than
the placebo group
my other bait can really always carry
the lemon slices in her purse and she
would sniff a few and she was feeling a
little bit nauseous oh and she always
carried sour candies too so your friend
can really might be right
research has shown that inhaling lemon
essential oils can help relieve nausea
and vomiting also at the National
Institute of cancer research has
suggested sucking on sour candies as a
way to relieve nausea and vomiting so I
always suggest having a few slices of
lemon in your kitchen squeezing some
lemon juice into your water or keeping
those sour candies on hand when you're
feeling sick so whenever I feel nauseous
hashtag mommy like hashtag mom to beat
hashtag motherhood crash fake milk I
just set the kettle and make myself some
peppermint tea works every time
yeah peppermint is often used to treat
nausea but whether it works or not is
totally up for debate
a lot of the research out there is
anecdotal but if it works for you go for
it
so my sister-in-law just had a baby yep
Debbie's a hot aunt now and she told me
that she took vitamin b6 supplements to
hell with her morning sickness Oh
Congrats aunt Debbie
so there's actually some promising
research when it comes to vitamin b6 so
one trial found that women who were
supplemented with b6 had a reduction in
nausea and vomiting
I admit I definitely took some b6
supplements today so I was having
something really important like a TV
segment but I always recommend that you
try to get a little bit in each day so
look for sources of b6 in foods like
potatoes fish and non citrus fruits so I
read and cause with that high carb is
the way to go to kill those nausea vibes
and you know personally I'm always on
the hashtag love carb live but if it
helps with nausea maybe I can make an
exception so for anyone that's ever been
pregnant you've probably kept a massive
box of saltine crackers by your bed is
there any evidence well a lot of it is
anecdotal and done just because we've
always recommended it like from the
1900s now a lot of organizations still
recommend going high carbs but there's
not a whole lot of evidence to support
that but if you're going to go high carb
make sure you choose your carbs wisely
and look for things that are higher in
fiber if you can tolerate them so things
like whole grain breads high-fiber
cereals and fibrous fruits and
vegetables
well now I'm confused cuz I've also read
an article that says you should go
high-protein what's the deal with that
so recently the research community has
drifted away from high carb and it's
been recommending a high-protein diet
instead one study found that women in
their first trimester were put on a
high-protein diet
experienced less nausea and vomiting
than two women who were put in the high
carb diet while my girl Shelley could
not even be in the same room as me
during her pregnancy so like going high
protein for some people could be really
difficult I'm experiencing the exact
same thing
so I would recommend choosing
plant-based proteins like soy edamame
and pulses well what about fluids aren't
doctors always teaching us that we need
to drink more fluids you're definitely
right Debbie this is a really common
recommendation but like a lot of the
other foods we've talked about today
maybe there's not a whole lot of
evidence to support it yes you want to
make sure that you're drinking enough
and maybe a little bit more water of
course if you've been vomiting and you
need to replenish some of those lost
fluids however whether you're not
drinking more consistently will help you
eliminate your nausea is still up for
debate
my tip is to listen to your body and to
drink flat not bubbly water as needed
oh I mean this pregnancy leg is gonna
stop we'll be okay Deb at the end of the
day sometimes you just can't avoid
morning sickness in fact the Society of
obstetrics and Gynecologists of Canada
recently stated that there really isn't
any strong evidence to suggest that any
foods can help to relieve symptoms
sometimes we just have to deal with it
but having said that the Society also
recommended that pregnant women try to
eat mindfully and choose whatever
pregnancy safe foods that they enjoy
that's a recommendation that I can
totally get behind because everybody is
so different especially when it comes to
nausea bottom line do what works best
for you and find that happy place where
you're feeling your best well guys I
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below for the moms out
there with what worked for you and it
comes to morning sickness subscribe to
the channel and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]